congratulations for Yasmin Fushimi the
newly elected general secretary of the
Social Democratic Party though she's a
comparative unknown it's now her job to
be the public face of the SPD and
provides support for the head of the
party
Fahim II had a strong showing winning
the post with about 88 percent of the
vote on Sunday I had hopes for this show
of support and I'm pleased to be
starting the job with such a definite
mandate which is encouraging but I'm
also aware that it sets a target for me
to meet when you're elected as a
newcomer to the office you have to do
justice to that vote of confidence is
not to listen in my languages as general
secretary Yasmin Fahim II will have to
help sharpen the party's platform and
image as the junior partner in the grand
coalition the SPD runs the risk of being
plowed under by the Christian Democrats
it's a daunting task and Fahim II is a
former trade union official who has
little experience in national politics
before Spitzer she's a top-notch I
didn't know her at all before but she's
got the brains and the heart for the job
she won the backing of the party and the
vote shows that everyone has to start
somewhere and she's no greenhorn she has
a trade union background and that's also
a national issue so she has plenty of
organizational experience this is where
yes-men Fahim II gained her experience
at the trade union offices of the mining
chemical and energy industry where she
was head of political planning now her
office is full of moving boxes not
everyone here will be sad to see her
leave though no one is willing to speak
on camera
some say that Fahim e has a reputation
for arrogance and there's even gossip
that she owes her career to her partner
who heads the union one of the people
who knows her well is department head
Ralph Becker he was for him EES boss
several years ago then conflicted when
conflicts start to simmer she finds a
way out of them and a way to solve them
that's one of her strengths and she can
be quite adamant when people get stuck
in hard-line positions then she tends to
be very incisive direct and
goal-oriented in her arguments the Glock
ninis that's usually those qualities are
likely also what attracted the attention
of SPD heads Sigmar Gabriel he backed
her candidacy but Yasmin Fushimi also
brings with her strong contacts to
business and industry within the Union
she's known as a longtime supporter of
the energy industry some of her critics
have even accused her of inappropriate
lobbying
no 2d physics is just Watson it's
actually a good thing that I have
contacts and no people on boards of
corporations I have experienced talking
to industry representatives of course
the party will benefit from those
contacts provides unsigned bands have
such entities as Federal Minister for
Economic Affairs in energy SPD head
Zigman Gabriella's also strengthening
his own position by bringing Fushimi on
board her election also helps bring a
modern and cosmopolitan face to the
party
Fahim e's father was born in iran but
she herself does not find that
particularly noteworthy maybe it has
shaped me as a person and given me a
more open view of things and maybe
curious about things that are different
from me
I don't shy away from things that are
new or different
yasmin Fahim ease move into the ranks of
the SPD leadership is a mark of her
fortitude now it's up to her to prove
that she can live up to the vote of
confidence